in this video we're going to be doing a
little bit of a change of pace rather
than talking about how to make videos
and how to do cool effects and all kinds
of stuff i'm actually going to talk
about learning to play an instrument
about two years ago we did a video
called freak guitar accident where uh i
play guitar and i learned how to
visualize the notes as if it's a music
game in real life
[Music]
well i was actually playing the game
rocksmith back then which was an ubisoft
game and
i actually learned how to play guitar
playing that game so that's what i'm
actually going to be talking about in
this video is using video games to learn
how to play guitar but here i'm going to
play band fuse and band fuse does things
a little bit differently it uses
tablature which is actually really
useful because
if you ever want to actually just read
guitar sheet music it's written in tab
form with numbers representing which
fret you're supposed to push on the way
these games work is pretty neat there's
actually a tone detection built in and
you have a quarter inch to usb that goes
into your xbox or into your ps3 and the
games will throw notes at you coming
down the track and you just watch the
screen and you play it kind of like it's
guitar hero but you're playing a real
guitar as you play the game over and
over you're going to see your score go
up and you're going to see the game
levels getting harder in other words
you're going to see yourself getting
better at guitar and you see it from the
very first time you start and every song
thereafter you get a little bit better
check it out i'll show you how it works
[Music]
magazines
so you guys get the idea it throws
numbers at you numbers correspond to the
threat
you push that fret down and you plug
that string it's kind of like reading
guitar hero but this time coming
sideways with the number you start off
and your finger's going to feel like
little frozen sausages and they're going
to be super slow but as you keep doing
it you're going to get faster and faster
and your technique's going to get there
which is a lot of fun and really
rewarding i'm playing things a little
faster than most you know beginners
would probably want but i'm actually
going to interrupt the difficulty a
little bit more so you guys can see what
happens when you get better
let's take it to experts
[Music]
[Music]
so if any of you guys have been like
wanting to pick up an instrument not
quite sure where to start
trying out a music game like band fuse
is
a really cool way to get introduced to
the guitar and i highly recommend you
check it out because learning how to
play an instrument learning how to play
music
is a great art form and a great piece of
craftsmanship you can have
if you guys are working on videos being
able to write your music is super great
case in point sam writing all the sweet
songs for all our sweet videos
i actually learned how to play guitar
playing a video game and i actually
think that's really cool
and something that's worth sharing and
making people aware of because
i like playing instruments i really love
music i think a lot of people out there
could pick up instruments if they just
had an easy way to learn in a game like
band fuse makes it really easy to learn
welcome to the future you guys lucked
out you're born in the right era
considered a video game public service
announcement for you guys alright until
then
peace out homies
you